This video is sponsored by loot crate,
the monthly subscription service for
epic Geek and Gamer items and pop
culture gear more on Luke crate at the
end of the video.
Hey,
wise crack jared again.
And today we're looking at the candy
flavored fever dream that is adventure
time with Finn and Jake.
Now in their final season of adventures,
we want it to look at what makes the
show so special.
And while there are lots of reasons
people love adventure time,
I'm going to argue it has a lot to do
with a storytelling style as old as
written storytelling itself and an epic
to epic for most to finish d elliot.
So let's see how adventure time tells a
story.
And as always spoilers ahead.
Of course,
some of the similarities to the classics
of old come down to the Ed venturing
part.
The classics have monsters,
dramatic rescues,
long journeys to Distinct Kingdoms and a
beautiful princess that sends soldiers
to battle.
The Elliot is also sometimes referred to
as the song of helium and is written in
verse giving it strong links to music.
Likewise,
adventure time features,
plenty of music and songs throughout at
seasons.
Thank you.
Pancakes making big and pancakes takes a
big enough to put it in a cake.
And characters even occasionally speak
in rhyme.
I've caught thumb thing for you.
Oh my whole show,
don't you know?
Yeah.
Might Stub your toe.
The Elliot and adventure time.
Also both start with a musical call to
hear their story.
Thanks your time.
Grab your friends to fairy dust and
lands right.
But what really connects adventure time
with epics like the Iliad,
the Odyssey or the alien is a surprising
one.
The structure of poetry.
Rebecca sugar,
former adventure time writer,
one set of show Creator Pendleton Ward.
He's expressing thoughts about very
modern feelings that people have.
Good poetry is like that.
Many of the things that venture time is
known for have origins in poetry.
It's mix of modern and classical
language.
Fast,
tight,
you fun to do.
It's music.
It's use of colorful and evocative
imagery.
The invention of new words,
objects and creatures.
Oh my God,
you guys.
Drama bomb and just how plain surreal at
all is.
But one of the most telling ways it
relates to poetry is in its length
adventure times episodes only last
roughly 10 minutes,
half your average TV show,
which means each episode relies on
compression.
Can you hear any story?
It's been compressed.
It jettisons the boring details for the
exciting stuff,
classical poetry and a lot of modern
poetry to hustle pre from rules on how
this compression is achieved.
The Elliot,
for instance,
compresses each line in toy form of
poetic rhythm or meter called Deck Tilak
Heck Salmon,
which is a fancy way of saying each line
must be exactly 18 silk.
Almost all poetry,
even if it doesn't use meter,
is a mode of compression and sure movies
compressed stories to a few hours.
TV compresses them to under an hour,
but adventure time is even more hardcore
compressing a whole story in to 10
minutes.
This type of stripping down requires the
essential elements be focused on in
imaginative ways.
In the episode [inaudible] Fin lives an
entire lifetime in a pillow dimension or
he gets married,
has kids,
and grows old all in 10 minutes.
This economy of exposition shows how
compression feeds creativity and helps
focus the story and unlike other stories
that get compressed in infuriating ways.
Game of thrones season seven venture
time uses this compression to be more
outlandish.
The first shot of boy features raining
knives outside,
which shows us why the characters are
stuck indoors within the first second
without having to tell us,
but aside from just both poems and
adventure time are short.
We can also draw similarities between
how they use these narratives.
Snippets to tell a larger story.
Traditionally in an epic poem,
the Iliad,
the text is broken up into paragraphs
called stanzas.
Stanzas composed larger chapters called
Cantos from the Italian word for song.
You could see a season of a TV show as a
canto and an episode as a stanza.
The stands focuses on the individual and
their feelings,
a short vignette or seen.
It gives an insight into someone's
character even if it lasts a lifetime,
like in the [inaudible] episode.
It Canto,
on the other hand is the accumulation of
the scenes that tell the story of
several characters or a whole world in
Dante's inferno,
another epic poem,
the stands that will be a short
interaction or description,
but the canto will be the story of a
whole circle of hell.
Just like the Elliot and other epics.
Adventure time tells it stories on a
micro and macro level.
Not only are there the contain
narratives of each episode,
but an overall narrative that reflects
the history of the land of uz through
dialogue,
geography,
and even just certain names.
We discover the different types of
government and rulers.
Who Has Kim,
oh,
Ooh,
that the main deity is a cosmic owl and
especially from the episode Simon and
Marcy,
it's hinted that ou was formed after a
nuclear apocalypse.
One of the most interesting ways in
which adventure time can be compared to
poetry is with something called Bathos.
Bathos is a sort of anticlimax a sudden
shift in tone or thoroughly mediocre and
to a suspenseful moment.
There are some great examples of this
and the classics like the defeat of
Achilles and invincible warrior brought
down by the Lamest of weaknesses is heel
and in paradise lost.
We learned that divine angels defecate
not through their poop shoots but from a
kind of missed from their skin that is
bathos something built up then brought
crashing down to earth.
Adventure time is full of this.
Just when something gets too dangerous
or scary,
I have come for you or romantic,
kiss me,
Thin Amin,
kiss me.
Then it's either interrupted or undercut
by another character undermining it or
it off.
Yeah,
busy crossing you,
man.
No,
he's just hugging me gently.
Well,
venture time is not the only show to use
bath.
Those for the sake of humor,
how things are going.
Again,
easy here.
Ooh,
child things,
they'll get pride.
It certainly helps make some of the more
creepy moments palatable to a younger
audience.
Beth,
this is also often integral to the
storytelling and the moral message of
the show.
Characters.
Usually villains are introduced and
dispensed with in an episode and even
longstanding ones like the ice king
develop using bathos.
I was going to start up on the
elliptical again,
but I got depressed.
Okay.
One of the key lessons you learned from
adventure time is prejudice is bad or
the more cliched.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
This is accomplished by setting up a
villain as evil and then finding out
they're simply misunderstood as is.
I'm hot again.
Thanks
dunes or a good guy who was a villain
all along.
This type of bathetic technique is used
frequently in poetry,
both from antiquity and today.
It is also a linchpin for character arcs
and adventure time and an integral part
of how it tells its story.
Although some sea adventure time as
prime TV for stoners,
I am the dream warrior.
I have summoned you here to hang with me
and you're together.
Dream.
Are you going to show us a move to beat
the farm?
There's a fierce fandom out there who
have invested a lot of time interpreting
the shows,
rather fake narrative.
The same can also be set up poetry,
which can oftentimes seem intentionally
cryptic end.
Even though poetry isn't as cool as
whoever this Jake Paul Dude is.
Adventure time is a prime example of how
millennia old poetic techniques are
still being used to tell funny,
sensitive,
and downright weird stories and two
extraordinary effect.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.
Now that you've got your storytelling
fix,
why not continue the adventure and
checkout loot crate for less than 20
bucks a month?
Loot crate sends you Keke and Gamer
collectibles and apparel right to your
door.
It's the best place to go for monthly
swag from your favorite franchises,
including adventure time.
And when you enter the code wisecrack
you'll get 10% off a new subscription.
The December loot crate team is explore
reminding you that no matter what you're
looking for,
you got to get out there and find it.
It's packed full of items from destiny
two guardians of the galaxy volume two
star wars and a mystery franchise.
So you're not going to want to miss this
crate.
You only have until the 19th at 9:00
PM Pacific time to sign up and receive
this explore crate.
So don't wait to get going and get 10%
off with the code wisecrack.
So click here or check out the link in
the description to head to loot,
crate.com/wise
crack to nab those exclusive items from
those powerful franchises.
Thanks to loot crate for sponsoring this
video and as always,
catch y'all next time.
Peace.